the same y i go to
and so i'm looking forward to that
because you know he has to he set scenes
on streets that i travel every day so i
want to i want to see what george has
done
tell us what you're reading this summer
send us a tweet at book tv
now on book tv encore book notes
iris chang was on book notes in 1997 to
talk about her book the rape of nan king
the forgotten holocaust of world war ii
it documents the atrocities upon the
people of nanking by the japanese
military during the early years of world
war ii
it's about an hour
irish chang author of the rape of nan
king the forgotten holocaust of world
war ii
when did you first think about writing
this book
well
it goes back a long way i mean i learned
about this event when i was a little
child but i really didn't think about
writing the book until i finished my
first one thread of the silkworm and
after i had attended a conference in
california that was devoted to
preserving the history of this event
what was the rape of manking the rape of
name king is one of the greatest
atrocities of world history in december
of 1937 the japanese swept into the
capital of china which was then nan king
and within six to eight weeks they
butchered raped and tortured hundreds of
thousands of chinese civilians three
hundred thousand people ultimately died
during this massacre and they raped uh
an estimated two
let's see twenty thousand to eighty
thousand women during this period why is
there such a discrepancy between twenty
thousand and eighty thousand it's often
very difficult to ascertain the exact
number many women were reluctant to come
out with these uh these facts at the
time
i'm looking at page 59 and there's a
gentleman here by the name of nakatomi
hakudo who who was he or who is he well
he he was a doctor
he's a doctor now but back in 1937
he was one of the soldiers who committed
atrocities in nan king
and there is a uh i'm going to read
something here just a moment but
have you met him
no no i mean this this is taken uh from
from an article but uh the story was
just so compelling that i had to put in
my book before i read this tell me what
the story is
well he was in
uh are we talking about the story in the
article itself well the story about him
now is a shrine
he's a doctor he's a doctor now and
he feels
so terrible about what he did so he has
put
pictures of the i guess some of the
atrocities in the waiting room of of his
clinic and
so patience of his can see what he did
in in king
let me read just a little bit from what
you've got in your book i remember being
driven in a truck along a path that had
been cleared through piles of thousands
and thousands of slaughtered bodies wild
dogs were gnawing at the dead flesh as
we stopped and pulled a group of chinese
prisoners out of the back
then the japanese officer proposed a
test of my courage he unsheathed his
sword spat on it and with a sudden
mighty swing he brought it down on the
neck of a chinese boy cowering before us
the head was cut clean off and tumbled
away on the group as the body slumped
forward blood spurting
in two great gushing fountains from the
neck the officer suggested i take the
head home as a souvenir i remember
smiling proudly as i took his sword and
began killing people
why'd you
you know you obviously this
bothered you why did you put this in
there i wanted to show people that the
japanese soldiers were inculcated to
commit violence
this is not a story that
was an isolated incident i mean it this
was happening throughout nan king and
they they
massacred people on all the way up to
the capitol and they even held killing
contests in order to
to desensitize the japanese soldiers
from
from feeling reluctant in committing
these atrocities got a picture here of
corpses along the yangtze river
right here the big one
where did you find this picture
this picture uh that one came from
that's uh
moriasi uh
yeah that's a a japanese correspondent
who took that picture that was reprinted
in several other publications
so um
it's
it's really
i'm telling you that's not the most
gruesome picture there you may not want
to show
the audience some of the others that are
in my book well actually i think
we do want to show the picture so that
they can see the
i mean not that picture on the other
side if we can pick it up on the other
side that picture right there
what's this
uh the one on the left
right here oh right
that's a number of uh heads that have
just been put out you know they've this
was the typical scene in and king
beheadings
then sometimes they would put heads up
on posts like that picture underneath
so that people could understand what it
would be like if they've continued to
resist japan and where was this done
this was this was done in king but also
throughout i mean throughout china
actually
what was the history of why the japanese
were in china in 1937 and then king
well in
1937 the japanese found an opportunity
to provoke a war with china and it's
called the marco polo bridge incident
and
we probably don't have too much detail
to go into the we don't have too much
time to go into that but
it escalated into
a full-scale war and the japanese
invaded shanghai
uh
in in the fall of
and the the
they had originally thought that the war
would take
a place only
only three months they thought that they
could conquer china in a matter of
months but when
one battle alone in one chinese city
shanghai dragged on for that long
the japanese were anxious to i think
make an example of a city they were they
were furious and frustrated and
that was the mood that the soldiers were
in as they marched from shanghai to name
king where is nan king in china nan king
is situated in a bend of the yangtze
river it is
maybe we can show a map right now
i'll find it go ahead
it's uh it's only a few miles away it
just shows the massacre
location that's right
shanghai would be
on the coast of china and this and then
kings further inland and um
the city is right in this in uh like
situated right at the bend of where the
the river courses um
uh you know
to the north and then turns to flow
um
uh towards the coast so when the
japanese swept towards nanking they had
all they had to do was encircle it from
three other lo
three other um directions because this
the river itself formed a natural
barrier
have you been to the nan king absolutely
how many times uh actually
in the summer of 1995 i was there for uh
you know for several weeks actually just
one time and what's your personal
connection to nan king
well um my my father was born in that
area and my family actually
uh my grandparents used to live in
nanking and they were almost separated
forever
shortly before the um
the massacre itself
and when did you first can you remember
the first time you ever heard about the
rape of men yes i was a little girl
i don't remember exactly how old i was
but
i must have been a grade school at the
time and my parents were professors
at the university of illinois at urbana
were telling me about the nanjing that
usha which is chinese for the nang king
massacre
and they said that the
killing had been so intense
in nanking that the river
the nanjing river literally read ran red
with blood for days and they
said that people were being
hacked to pieces
and at the time this was
this was very hard for me to to
visualize and i really wanted to learn
more about it so i went to the local
libraries to see if i could find
anything about it and
there wasn't a single book in english on
it i couldn't find anything
so what'd you do next oh well i think as
a child i probably just forgot about it
and i didn't really think about it for
another 20 years
the rape and king didn't intrude in my
life until
until i was married and i was living in
santa barbara and a filmmaker friend of
mine told me
that uh that he had two friends who um
who had heard that that people were uh
had had been filming a documentary on
the rape and king but that they had
problems securing
funding i think for distribution because
of japanese influence in this country
and that's what piqued my interest again
and
i located the filmmakers and and talked
to them and
one of them nancy tong who
produced the documentary in the name of
the emperor told me that there was
considerable chinese activism on this
event and that if i was interested
i should contact
you know this particular organization
which is called the alliance for the
preservation of
the truth of world war ii and as it
turns out this particular organization
was hosting a conference on the rape of
name king in december 1994 so
since i was in santa barbara and the
conference was to be held in cupertino
i just drove up and attended the uh the
event now
what i wasn't prepared for was the fact
that they had put poster-sized
pictures of some of these atrocities and
i was seeing these pictures for the very
first time
and
i was
i remember i felt sick to my stomach and
i mean i really
um i i thought at one point that i would
have to go home because i was just so
ill you know i and i resolved to do
something you know i thought
this was so bad and yet no one had still
written a book about it so i figured
that it was time
to uh
you know to take initiative who is this
woman up here lee shoeing
lee showing
is she alive
oh yes she is
and what's the story well
back in in 1937 she was a teenage
wife of a technician who had fled from
the city of nan king
on top of a train and she was left
behind in the city and she ended up
fighting off
three soldiers who tried to rape her
they stabbed her more than 30 times
where does she live now she lives in nan
king did you talk to her yes i did how
long um i spoke to her for several hours
and i felt like a time traveler because
i saw this picture of her you know when
she was still a teenager
and and when i met her face to face she
was almost 80 years old what's she look
like now
well she's still a very
she's a very feisty woman she's
very strong one of the strongest women
i've ever met
she's she's
um
well she's she has so many wrinkles now
that they've covered up the scars but
when she was younger the scars on her
face were horrible
again she was
stabbed 37 times with bayonets that's
correct
can you remember anything else about the
story where was she at the time she was
stabbed she was hiding in the
international safety zone which was a
neutral
zone organized by the foreigners of nan
king to protect them from the japanese
and we'll probably talk more about that
later but at the time
a soldier had his eye on her when when
he went down into into the basement
where she was hiding and
he tried to rape her but she resolved to
fight the death to prevent from being
raped so
luckily she was bigger than he was so
that when he lunged i guess when he came
for her she she uh like ripped
his bayonet from its sheath and and she
she threw i guess her back against the
wall and she just started grappling with
him and she ended up using him as a
human shield against the two other
soldiers who were trying to stab her and
protect
you know
him but she was using him as a as a
shield to prevent from getting slashed
up how did she survive
well she survived just barely
one bayonet
stabbed her right in in the stomach and
she eventually lost her baby
but she she fainted and she was almost
buried alive by her family who didn't
realize that she was still alive but
someone noticed the bubbles the blood
frothing from her mouth and they rushed
her to the hospital where
the american doctor robert wilson saved
her life
now
she's now 80 some years old when you
talk to her how did
how many times did somebody ask her
about this over the years oh um i think
i think other reporters had talked with
her i'm not really sure
you talk about your dad being born near
there what about your grandparents
well
my mother's
parents were
in nan king
in 1937
my i mean my my grandfather actually
was was in the city as the japanese were
bombing it and uh
and there's just an incredible story of
how how they were almost separated
forever during the chaos that followed
the the mass evacuations what happened
after that i mean i know this i
read the story but tell us more about it
okay um you see
when when the fighting in
shanghai um escalated it just became
clear to my grandfather that
his wife who was then a young woman in
her 20s wasn't really safe he didn't
want her to be in the city where the
japanese were bombarding hospitals and
schools and so he sent her to her home
village which was
near the city of
and
when he he went back to visit her in the
village but then when he journeyed back
to nanking he didn't realize that the
entire capital was moving inland and
that his particular unit was was just
they were leaving they were going to
leave town and and he
had to get word to my grandmother to
join him uh in another city so that they
could
leave that whole region and
they were to meet in wuhu because i
think some of the
the railroad tracks to nan king had
already been bombed and so
as he waited for her you know she didn't
show up she waited for four days and he
didn't know that it was just taking a
long time
because
uh the transfer i mean the railroads had
been bombed out and everyone was trying
to get on a sampon to get out of there
and so he waited and waited eventually
it got to be
it it got to the point where
he really had to make a choice he would
either leave the city
and leave wuhu
and and maybe never see his wife again
or he could wait for his wife and his
daughter
and
and then
meet up with them but
miss the boat out of the region knowing
that that area would be overrun by
japanese soldiers
and
he was so desperate right when he turned
to leave he he screamed at her name
he pay just screamed it out and
in one last sampon
it happened that she was my grandmother
was in there and she stuck her head out
and yelled back and and it was because
of that fateful cry that they were
reunited otherwise
um you know otherwise my mother would
have never been born they probably would
have never seen each other again
when did they leave china
uh they didn't leave china until shortly
before the 1949 communist revolution
so um that that would have been sometime
in the 1940s are they alive
unfortunately both have passed away my
grandfather lived up to
be 94 years old and he passed away
in 1993 and my grandmother
died this this last summer it's very
unfortunate she didn't get to see the
publication of this book and did you
talk to both of them about the material
in this book yes actually my grandfather
because he was a poet and a journalist
and a book author he had written about
some of this in his autobiography but i
did have a chance to interview my
grandmother as well and she provided
some more details before she died and
where did you grow up i grew up in
champaign-urbana illinois
which is where my parents were
professors how long did you live there
first almost exactly 20 years i moved
there when i was
my father was offered a position when i
guess i was about one i went to school
there went to the university and and
left i think at age 21. and are they
still there yes they are
and where did you move after you left
champaign well um
i worked briefly as a reporter for the
chicago tribune and the associated press
in chicago
and then i went to the johns hopkins
university writing seminars program
where i received my master's degree
then i got married and moved out to
california where my husband was working
and where do you live now i live in
sunnyvale california which is
which is the heart of silicon valley
you say in the book that the japanese
have never apologized for this that's
correct never officially apologized
why
well i think because there's there's
really no reason for them to do so
unless they were pressured to do so
and why hasn't somebody pressured him to
do so i mean you compared a lot with
what the germans have done
well i think maybe demographics has
something to do with it i mean some of
this activism behind the event is fairly
new but i would say the cold war has a
large
uh role in this the silence of of of the
japanese and the the chinese and the
americans on this issue
um
after the uh the communist revolution
neither i think the prc nor the roc
really wanted to pressure japan to pay
reparations
uh and and to um apologize because both
of them needed japan as an ally against
each other they needed japan for
economic and political reasons and
the united states also sought out japan
as
its ally as well against the forces of
communism in asia
back in 1937 how many people lived in
nanking
before the bombings
before some of the evacuations about a
million people and what was the
relationship between china and japan
back then what was going on in the world
and what was their relationship
back in 1937 oh things by that point had
been tense i mean
in the summer of
1937 uh japan had uh
um
had attacked uh shanghai
this i mean that this is the
they had uh war was had already broken
out but what was the reason
well um it goes back a long way but i
the japanese had actually for hundreds
of years ambitions in china it's it's
really it's not something that um
it was not something that just started
in 1937.
it was uh it has there's a long history
of animosity here what's the reason
reason for the animosity
well
again you know we
i don't know if we have enough time to
go into this but um there had already
been uh you know war between
you know there was a there was a first
sino-japanese war and uh there had been
already um
numerous attempts by the japanese to
carve up
parts of china
they had already seized in manchuria by
the 1930s
what was it and and what is it about
what was it the japanese character that
led to this kind of slaughtering i mean
what did you find in this process i
assume you've asked people about that
see it's it's very complicated actually
another historian said that
trying to peer into the japanese mind
was like trying to stare down a black
hole it's it's very
very difficult often to find out the
motives for this
i would say though that um if you're
looking at the the soldiers themselves
you'll find that many of them had been
so brutalized
uh before the massacre that um
that i think that the rape the the ma
the nang king massacre was
was an episode in which just this much
of the pent-up frustration that they had
experienced had exploded
so the japanese the japanese soldier was
um systematically um hazed for years
uh before nan king i mean he was
you have to imagine just how
how intense the the japanese military
experience really was
he had to endure
getting slapped around by
japanese
officers i mean there were there are
accounts of japanese soldiers being
forced to wash their underwear they were
treated
almost as subhuman within their own army
and it's often been suggested that those
who have the least power can become the
most sadistic when they do gain
some chance to unleash the frustration
that was bottled inside how much
discussion have you had with japanese
people
about this event
i i had to operate i had the opportunity
to talk to a group of japanese students
who were who are studying in san
francisco and they were absolutely
shocked to find out what happened i mean
they had been kept in the dark about
this all their lives they said that
their
their textbooks had contained only one
line on the nanking massacre which i
think was referred to as the nanjing
incident
and
i remember that when i showed them some
of the photographs i think one one woman
burst into tears
so it's clear that the me that many of
the japanese people to this day don't
really know what happened
i mean the ignorance in japan on this
event and on other atrocities is
appalling
if you if you look i mean i i talked
with a college professor
in japan
and and he said
that
when he mentioned to his students
remember these are college students that
japan had been
at war with the u.s
many of these students asked him which
side won
so in other words
they're not being taught about this in
school and the ministry of education has
for decades
censored this event and others from
their textbooks i mean this has been
the subject of a 30-year lawsuit between
the japanese government
and a famous historian there inaugura
is there a chinese holocaust museum
well there actually is a rape of an king
museum in nanjing
it has the big a big number 300 000
inscribed on it
but that's about it and but i've met
people in los angeles who are interested
in building a chinese holocaust museum
uh in this country you say that the
house of representatives got into this
well actually that's no that's something
different that's the lipinski bill no i
didn't mean that they got into the
holocaust museum they got into this
whole issue of the rape event that's
right
william lipinski
who is the democrat from illinois has
introduced a bill in congress that calls
for the japanese to officially apologize
to its world war ii of victims and to
pay reparations
and the rape of nan king is only one
aspect of the bill he lists many other
atrocities such as you know the korean
comfort women issue
the medical experimentation that the
japanese had conducted
including vivisection without anesthesia
on american and chinese prisoners of war
um
you know the baton death march there
there are so many other instances of
wartime atrocity that are mentioned in
his bill and uh
it's i think they have more than uh 30
supporters right now in congress what
was the killing contest you mentioned it
earlier how did it work the killing
contest yes well there were two
sub-lieutenants who
wanted to see who could kill
a hundred
chinese first and the japanese media
covered this avidly as if it was some
kind of sporting event
and
they they when they reached the you know
the hundred mark they i guess they had
lost counts they figured okay let's just
up it up let's just up this to 150.
you've got uh what the actual newspaper
that's right that's right and you can
see over here the numbers 105 and 106.
what's that that that's how close they
were they were running neck to necks you
see you know one had killed
105 people another had lopped off 106
heads and that was actually published in
the japanese industry that's right so
this was clearly something the japanese
people knew about at the time
who was conducting the contest
oh these two these two subjects i mean
who was challenging them whose idea was
it that they do it i'm not really clear
on the details of this but um but this
was not typical this was what's
happening throughout nan king here's the
picture says and then king the japanese
turn murder into sport note the smiles
on the japanese in the background and
here's the photo right there
where do you find all these photos many
of these photos were later collected by
the name king government
for their war crimes
tribunals against the japanese after the
war
but sometimes the japanese soldiers
themselves took these pictures
when i talked with one of the survivors
he remembers that as he stood uh you
know on the edge of this pit watching
all the japanese lop off heads and throw
them in a you know to the side and what
you know one person was keeping count
keeping score and the other one was uh
laughing and taking photographs you know
there's an incredible story about how
this one album of 16 photographs
eventually made its way from photoshop
to
uh to like a to a toilet you know to
and it was hidden for years until it
finally ended up in an archives
a couple of these pictures in here are
rough to look at
i'm children yet are you
was it a tough decision to put them in
the book
it was it was i was very concerned that
some of these pictures
would result in the book being banned
from
school libraries but um i had numerous
discussions with this with you know the
people at harper collins and with with
other historians and friends and some
people
insisted that you know i put them in
anyway uncensored because this was
history this was the truth what's this
photo over here
um
that's a photo of a woman
who a rape victim who is being forced to
pose next to a japanese soldier naked
they found these photos in the wallets
of some of the japanese soldiers you
know they took them
and sometimes the the people in the
local photo mat would
would make copies because they knew how
important they were on the other page at
the top which that's what's that photo i
still have problems looking at it that's
a woman who's been impaled after
she's been raped right down here
and where did you find this
this again came came from china
and
it was it's it's it came from the
chinese archives and the photo above it
um that's a picture of a woman who's
been gang-raped and she as you could see
she's been tied to the chair so that she
could be raped
um
whenever the soldiers were in the mood
for it and
again i mean i have a hard time even
looking at these pictures even now
what's the purpose of putting them in
the book then what as you decided what
in the end what what was how the
conversation like between you and the
publisher
well
there were people in the publishing
house who had problems looking at the
pictures um
in the end we decided that it was just
it was important for people to see what
they were capable of doing and um it was
a tough decision i
um and i know that i might i may well
catch a lot of criticism for it but
i don't think that people will realize
just how brutal the japanese were until
they see these pictures
if i were a japanese sitting here and
saw these i would say things like what's
your proof that this actually is
something that was caused by a japanese
soldier
well all i can say is that there are
thousands of pages of primary
uh source documents on this event four
different languages that's that pretty
much describe with words these very
pictures
and um and many of these pictures
they're not they're not they don't
didn't all come from japan and china
many of them
can be found in the united states in the
missionary uh
collections let me show you this picture
right here and ask you to tell me what
it is
the one to the right the one up top
the bayonet the bayonetting well
these are pictures of the japanese
bayonetting
victims and and they're doing it for
practice they're using live prisoners as
practice and um
and
as you could see
um
this the gentleman the the chinese who's
been blindfolded i mean he's he's been
stabbed repeatedly
and this is happening even after he's
dead you say that's just practice it's
just practice below that this photograph
this is a photograph of
several japan several chinese victims
being buried alive as japanese soldiers
watch
and you also tell a story in there where
they would bury
some chinese
victims up to their heads and then have
german shepherds or tear them apart
tear them apart did you have any
pictures of that no
thank god how did you find that out um
well that that was that came out of our
you know archival documents and also
came out of
descriptions which i found in china i'm
telling you
literally i had so many facts on these
atrocities i i had i had to use a
computer database for them in order to
keep keep them
you know in order i mean i i we had that
much evidence on it if we had when did
you start writing this book or when did
you start compiling all the images i
started compiling the information
probably in january or february 1995.
and i noticed that as late as august
almost the end of august you had
something quoted in here from the japan
times and this book came out in december
how did you get it how would you were
able to publish it that close well you
see the we we really had to publish this
right at the last minute because all of
this activism it's ongoing and and um we
really were working right down to the
last minute on this book it was a very
tight schedule and why is you mean you
were afraid you're going to lose the
opportunity if you didn't get it
published right away it's it's it's a
long story i mean harpercollins itself
as you know has has been through some
difficulty and you know they eventually
canceled more than 100 book contracts
and and you know there were some delays
in the process but um
but that was okay because that gave me
the opportunity to put in some other
information that should have gone in the
book
um you know i i never thought for
instance that i would end up finding the
family of john robbie who is the nazi
hero of nan king and
you know i i located the diaries and
located the family halfway through the
project so i mean this was an ongoing
process
and you talked to his daughter
uh his granddaughter that's right ursula
reinhardt i mean that i've
tracked down the family when i think the
book was almost finished so um
so yes revisions were made up to the
last minute and who is john robbie john
robbie was the head of the nazi party in
nanking but he was also
the head of the international safety
zone committee in nanking which is that
group of about 20 foreigners who decided
to create in name king a two and a half
square
mile
area for the refugees during the
massacre
they told the japanese that this area
was off limits to them
and they had to feed these refugees and
protect them from the japanese you have
a letter in here dated eight june 1938
and it's dear fuhrer signed by john
robbie that letter went to hitler
why
well he was hoping to stop the
atrocities by informing the highest
levels of german government about the
nanking massacre he
may he may have been a little naive but
he really thought that perhaps the
germans would
pressure the japanese to stop the
killing so what he did was in 1938 when
he went back to berlin he brought with
him a copy of john mcgee's film of the
massacre and john mcgee was was the uh
was the episcopalian minister who took
uh footage of
of uh some of the atrocities uh actually
he's the gentleman right right on the
other page actually which one uh the the
the picture
that's a little lower on the page which
one to the right
this gentleman okay fine we'll get it
here so people can see what he looks
like
yeah he shot scenes from the nan king
hospital
and um
it was this film that um was reproduced
and and you know in shanghai it was
smuggled out and inking and this
and they made several copies john robbie
took one of these copies he also kept
diaries of the mask or he brought those
along with him to to berlin and he he
sent a copy of the film to hitler and he
and he was hoping to make some kind of
i guess change in german policy towards
japan but the net result
of the uh of sending the film was was a
visit from the gestapo
and uh
they came to his home arrested him
interrogated him
uh for for uh hours
and uh eventually they
they forced him to promise them that he
would never
speak about the atrocities again where
is that film
that's a good question we are trying to
well the john mcgee's film is available
in the united states i mean several
copies were made so they're in different
archives and different homes but john
mcgee
sorry john robbie's copy
we don't know where it is because people
have searched the german archives and
they can't find it so to this day
they're not sure if hitler has really
seen it but the family's convinced that
he did if you saw the john mcgee film
what would you see do you see the
atrocities
you would see people being led away
by the japanese soldiers you have to
remember he couldn't just you know stick
the camera up you know right
in front of their faces this had to be
done secretly so you could see
some footage that
is filmed through like maybe a crack in
the door a crack in the window and you
would see crowds of chinese being taken
away and the most gripping images come
from the hospital where there were
victims who had
who had escaped
being burned alive people who had been
slashed with bayonets
there's one picture where one woman's
head is just about to fall off it's it's
really very grotesque
azuma shiro or shiro azuma depending on
how you pronounce it uh who is who
shirazuma is a japanese veteran of the
rape of name king
and he's still in in
he's still alive and he's in japan right
now and you corresponded with him that's
correct
how did that work how did you find him
well i had to track him down and
i think a journalist
ian buruma actually was the one who gave
me his address
and i i wrote a letter to him i had it
translated into japanese and
he responded
almost immediately and i had uh the
letter translated back into english he
sent me a copy of his diaries
and uh he also answered every question
that i had posed to him see i was trying
to understand the the the state of mind
that he was in at the time what did you
learn from him what i learned was that
the japanese soldier
really had to see the chinese as
subhuman before they could kill them i
mean he he depicted the chinese in his
diary as
you know as like animals or as insects
right above that
in the book
you can put this into context
a veteran officer named taminga now
tamina
tamanaga shozo recalled vividly his own
transformation from innocent youth to
killing machine
and i want to read
what you have and where did you find
that by the way um that was in the
secondary source it came from a book
he scooped water from a bucket with a
dipper then poured it over both sides of
the blade swishing off the water he
raised his sword in a long arc standing
behind the prisoner tanaka steadied
himself legs spread apart and cut off
the man's head with a shout yo
the head flew more than a meter away
blood spurted up in two fountains from
the body and sprayed into the hole the
scene was so appalling that i felt i
couldn't breathe
if you were japanese what would you want
your own people to do about this if they
didn't know about it
well
i guess it would depend on the
individual but
i i don't know what they would think but
i think that
i personally think that they have a
moral responsibility to come to grips
with this japan as a nation cannot move
forward until they
until they meet this squarely in the
face
well
even according to your testimony they
don't even know about it some of them
don't know about it but there are those
who do and um
i remember talking to some
some japanese who when they hear it
they'll often just immediately deny it
they don't want to believe it
so
it's very hard it's very hard to know
exactly how they're going to react even
when these facts are are thrust into
their face will your book be published
in japan uh
i'm not really optimistic that it will
be but
perhaps some kind of small radical
publisher will take a risk
and and put it out
from what you know what would happen if
it were
if books were
tried to be sold over in japan i don't
know but i'll tell you that
shiro zuma who's come out to apologize
for the for his role in the massacre
he's faced
countless death threats and um many of
the journalists who've written about
this in japan
um have either been ostracized or i mean
when you see them photographed they have
sunglasses on because you know they've
they've
run into these these kinds of threats
too um
don't forget the the japanese some
japanese right winger shot
i think the the the mayor of nagasaki in
the back simply because he
he said that he thought hirohito had
some responsibility
for the war
so in 1989 that's right
so um
we have a country that is living in
denial
and um
i'll be honest with you i i am
completely appalled that more people
don't know about this atrocity because
if you look i mean 300 000 people died
in nking and
300 000 people might not seem like a
huge number
until you place it in the context of
world war ii history three hundred
thousand deaths
is greater than
the deaths from hiroshima and nagasaki
combined
it's also greater than the combined
civilian deaths of several european
countries for the entire duration of
world war ii so in other words if you
add up
the number of civilians who died in
england france
and belgium
that still
would not be as many people
who died in nanking which is one chinese
city in six to eight weeks
in the end more than 19 million chinese
people
perished they they
19 million people were killed
what do you want to do with this
well
i i want the whole world to know what
happened i want the entire world
to know the truth and how far are you
willing to take it
well i think i've i've
just writing the book is is the
was the biggest step really for me
i think i've done my part in
in
just just laying down the facts for
people to read
and
also in the book you have some americans
one in particular is robert wilson who
was he
robert wilson is uh
was the missionary doctor
and he was the only surgeon in nan king
during the um the great massacre
and what role did he play
well he was the person who
ended up having to stitch up the
the survivors who came
you know straggling into the hospital
from bayonet
wounds or burn wounds and
he was working night and day it's it's
it's incredible what he was able to do
under this condition what was the zone
the international safety zone
it was two and a half square miles in
the middle of the city
which the the foreigners had uh marked
off with red crass flags
and um
and it was it was an area that they
claimed that the japanese were not
permitted to enter and they tried to
you know
they they just harbored the chinese
there
thousands of chinese were pouring into
the zone every day
many with only their clothes on their
backs and just begging for a place to
sit down so that they could be safe from
the from the japanese and how many
people were inside that zone um
hundreds of thousands one actually said
three hundred thousand one one of the
zone members said three hundred thousand
were in the zone and you tell a story
about how chinese soldiers would come in
yes
and then the japanese would come in and
how did they find them when they were
they took off their uniforms and put on
civilian clothes what was the technique
they used to find them well what they
did was they searched
their their hands to see if they had any
calluses from
handling guns they also even searched
their backs to see if there were any
backpack marks even their feet for signs
of marching and that way they were able
to find out who had been a former
chinese soldier and they systematically
marched them out and shot them
were there was there a trial of any kind
after all that war was over there were
um
well the biggest one was the tokyo war
crimes trial or the in itself the formal
name is the international military
tribunal for the far east
and um that was held in
japan and it resulted in some of the
class a war criminals
being hanged
by the end of it was that everything
that happened in world war ii happened
at this trial i mean it would cover
everything yes it was it was covering
they were trying to cover everything but
they also had a local trial too for
name king there was a name king tribunal
as well
and how long did that go on
um
it went on for several months it was
mainly these were held immediately after
the war and that was held in then king
yes of course the the international
tribunal for the far east lasted
considerably longer i mean went on for
years how much publicity was there for
this event either in japan or in in
kenya though there was considerable
publicity for the tokyo war crimes trial
i it was
i think was the longest war crimes trial
in history and they had you know
hundreds of reporters there
in king it was well publicized i'm sure
throughout china
you tell a story in the beginning of the
book about
commodore matthew perry
and how the americans opened up
japan to the outside world how'd that
work
oh um well
what
what perry decided to do when the
japanese ignored
requests from the american government to
open up their ports trade he he marched
up into
he he studied japanese history carefully
and then he decided that the best way to
to deal with them was to shock them into
submission and so he uh
he um kind of just came
right he just went right up
with you know to the to one of the ports
and he strode into the capitol with uh
with with some very aggressive looking
men and and it just terrified the
japanese at the time i mean this was
their the first time they had ever even
seen steam power
uh one historian said it would be
you know to to really understand the
pressure the japanese were under it
would be like
an announcement maybe on cnn
that
that we have uh some weird-looking
aircraft headed
towards earth that that was how shocked
they were at the time and this was in
july of 1853 yes was that the first time
japan had ever
seen an american
probably the first time many of them had
ever seen an american what happened to
the country after that well then they
decided to modernize and they they they
decided that they would they would
appease the barbarians but they would
they would try to learn from them
because it was obvious that they were
lagging
in in technology they had to learn to to
build up their military what happened
next to the country well the country did
precisely that and um there was the
meiji restoration and the entire country
became very nationalistic and
in the end they they built up a very
strong
military and and
and they began to get some of the
respect that they had craved actually
from the west that does the the rape of
nan king or the massacre at nankang have
any impact on the relationship today
between china and japan you ever did you
talk to folks about that when you went
over there well
it's actually very interesting that you
asked me that because
um
the many of the prc officials that i've
met there they're very they're
sympathetic to uh the history of the
rape and king i mean many of them may
have had relatives who died
during the sino-japanese war but at the
same time i think they are reluctant to
endanger
their their trade relations with japan
and also um the political and diplomatic
relations so
the prc has actually as i think i may
have mentioned before has expelled uh
activists who have tried to promote this
event actually promote the history of
the rape and nan king in the back of
your book in the epilogue you say
there's a number of lessons
for all this but this is one i wanted to
ask you about another lesson to be
gleaned from nan king is the role of
power
in genocide those who have studied the
patterns of large-scale killings
throughout history have noted that the
sheer concentration of power in
government is lethal that only a sense
of absolute unchecked power can make
atrocities like the rape of nanking
possible what would you say then about
today's chinese concentration of power
in that government well i think it's a
dangerous situation because we still i
mean the prc
to this day it's still a totalitarian
regime
and
it's it's
you know if you have these kinds of
conditions in place an atrocity like the
rape and can happen again what did they
think when you went to china in 1995 did
the officials know what you were doing
there
in 1995
no they didn't and actually
i was a little concerned when i went
back because i had just written the book
the thread of silkworm which is an
unauthorized biography of the father of
the red chinese missile program so i you
know and i knew that plenty of people
had been kicked out of china for
promoting the history of the rape and
inking so
i figured that there was a good chance
that i myself would be interrogated and
expelled from the country do they know
who you were
um
the people named kingdom all they knew
was that i was a scholar who was out
there seeking information
and you said you're married yes your
children not yet and what does your
husband do he's an electrical engineer
and he works in silicon valley and he's
been incredibly supportive of this
project and supportive of my career and
you said that you live in sunnyvale
which is right in silicon that's correct
and it seemed like there was somebody in
in this book that is living in sunnyvale
was it somebody that would admit so it
so turned out that there was a paramedic
uh
you know
in in nan king who now lives in
sunnyvale i mean
this is somebody who when he was
uh living in nanking back in 1937 i mean
he was he was a little boy and uh
but he had volunteered to help the uh
the chinese army he was working as a
paramedic at the time
sure coincidence
in the book you talk about in the
beginning of the rape of nan king a
an incident that 57 000 people were
killed
oh yes that must be the uh the moofal
mountain massacre that's correct and
what was that
well what they had done was they
they had kept these tens of thousands of
civilians
in in these camps and then eventually
after keeping them
dehydrated and starved
they just went out and just just started
machine gunning them killing them was
that the most that ever died at one time
i think it may have been
what's your sense of what would lead a
human being to do this kind of thing
i think
that i think that people are much more
capable of committing these atrocities
than
we would think and i think that if
you're conditioned to believe that what
you're doing is the right thing if
somehow
if the act of murder becomes like a holy
one then it would it would be uh easy i
think to to convince people that not
only what you're doing is is wrong but
that it is it's sanctioned by god and
that it is
it's it's the only right thing you can
do
have you talked at all about what
happened in rwanda
um
they're actually
in this book it mentions rwanda just
briefly but i i would say when i was
looking at the news accounts
you know i i
felt like i was reviewing my old
archival documents again it was that
some of the similarities were haunting
stories about
women who had been
raped by soldiers and now they're going
to carry an enemy soldier's baby and
and
these these dilemmas that were so
painful to me when reading them because
you know i kept seeing the same story
over and over again you tell a story in
here i think a woman to this day won't
give
her real name or what was it was raped
and i can't remember exactly what it was
but you alluded to it then what was that
that some of the rapes that happened
uh eventually children were born you see
yes some some there were many half
japanese half chinese children born as a
result of this rape and
one of the missionaries at the time
louis smith said that you know there
were thousands of these children
being smothered to death or drowned
because very few women really wanted i
mean they couldn't love these children
and but
you have to understand that they had it
must have been a terrible choice for
these women to make i mean
killing your own baby or raising a child
that you could never love and i'm sure a
lot of women couldn't make that choice
so at the same time there were thousands
of women also
committing suicide in the city i mean
there were uncounted women uh throwing
themselves into the youngster river to
drown how interested have you found
americans in this story
i am surprised the response i mean it's
overwhelming it seems to me that almost
everyone i've talked with is interested
and they're shocked they don't know
about this why don't we know about it in
the united states
well
i i i sometimes wonder if it's maybe
demographics
um
you know it's
it's it's really stunning to me that i i
really don't know the answer to that
question i mean i hope it's simply it
was just lack of interest
maybe there weren't enough
chinese and japanese experts
uh
you know immediately after the war
but you know the united states
government itself was engaged in a a
you know in the conspiracy with with
the japanese to cover up some of their
own
uh you know some of their own dealings
so there are many political reasons why
something like this wouldn't be told
what was that moment in here that you
talked about when
fdr
had uh that's correct how much 30
seconds of film or 30 minutes of film
take maybe 30 feet of film 30 feet of
film right see um yes the um
well as you know the japanese had bombed
the uss panay
and some americans had died as a result
of this bombing and uh the japanese
later on tried to excuse the the bombing
by saying well it was a cloudy day or we
couldn't really see clearly that this
was an american ship but
it wasn't by the way
it was a gun vote
and it was bombed on december 12th
yes yes
right right the japanese had entered the
city and um
but you know there were two newsreel men
aboard and one of them
uh well both of them took footage of the
japanese swooping down almost to deck
level to shoot at the the passengers and
it's clear from anyone who looks at the
footage that the japanese could see the
flags that were painted on the deck or
or flying overhead and
the president
specifically requested that this footage
be removed before it was shown in
american theaters why
well we could only speculate on the
reasons why
it's probably because they didn't want
to jeopardize any kind of settlement
that they wanted to make with japan
we're out of time this is our
guest book cover book jacket the rape of
nan king
and our guest has been iris chang thank
you very much thank you
the redesigned booknotes website now
features over